pas combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait deux
pattes un peu chez lui ne faut trop de
quoi monter bien sûr vaudois mois dans
votre attention
il me manque un
[Musique]
attac heures j'ai besoin d'être poursuit
l'invs est seul je termine mon
maquillage et je suis à toi j'ai compris
elle en a pour une heure je crois que ça
peut-elle mes yeux la bouche
je suis tout de même plus séduisante que
papa barre en a b c
je veux abîmé mais me tromper bien vivre
papa tard j'arrive on tard j'ai fini
[Musique]
les écoutes
nous allons tous vider mon tirelire et
puis nous irons à acheter dix assiettes
en porcelaine au grand bazar la
porcelaine il nous avons assez d'argent
[Musique]
c'est pas beau ça
moi ça sert à rien c'est décoratif
ah bon oui ta tirelire là sur l'étagère
tu veux me donner des sous je veux t'en
prendre à bon oui nous devons acheter un
nouveau service de ré c'est la patate à
je vis de tirelire ou la tienne est
lourde
tant mieux c'est là que je mets mes
vieux clous tu vois je suis économe
je ne jette rien il reste l'intérieur de
pata zut atteint 8 états unis
or with il encore j'ai cinq pièces mais
ce n'est pas pour acheter de la
vaisselle à leurs singles si le petit je
veux à cachetonner ou
ah ben zut et asie pacifique pata suite
oui oui pas tirelire je ne veux plus
comment ça j'avais c'est une pièce je
les ai perdus ou vraiment perdu oui je
suis certaine que tu m'as pas d'appart
attendu traitant avoir perdu sa tirelire
c'est une houle à dole d'auto forêt tous
les gâteaux groupe du m
pendant une semaine mais plus que je le
parle ou cherchant bien on finira bien
par là retrouvés sans eau
[Musique]
ben saoud
e
edit 2 3 4 5 et que j'en ai vite nous
trois pièces de droit car ces pièces le
godillot
on voit ce lapin
[Musique]
vous inquiète combien croyez-vous qu'il
y ait de papus ne faut trop d'écoles
beauté bien sûr faux toi
[Musique]